"
DEMOCRATS ARE MAKING IT NO
SECRET THAT THEY'RE SEARCHING
FOR A PLAN B.
AS PRESIDENT BIDEN STUMBLES HIS
WAY INTO BECOMING ONE OF THE
WORST PRESIDENTS IN AMERICAN
HISTORY.
HEADLINE AFTER HEADLINE SHOW
PARTY OFFICIALS FRETTING ABOUT
JOE'S OLD AGE AND PLUMMETING
POLLS.
WHO WILL SUCCEED JOE BIDEN?
>> WELL, YOU KNOW, THERE'S NO
QUESTION IN MY MIND THAT JOE
BIDEN IS DOING EXACTLY WHAT
NEEDS TO BE DONE FOR THIS GREAT
COUNTRY OF OURS.
WE ALL KNOW THAT OUR DEMOCRACY
IS TEETERING ON EDGE.
WE NEED A JOE BIDEN TO GET US
THROUGH THIS ROUGH PATCH.
I THINK HE'S DOING GREAT WITH
THAT.
WE KNOW THAT THIS FORECAST
INCLUDES VICE PRESIDENT HARRIS.
I SUPPORT HER.
AND I'M JUST SAYING THAT IF HE
CHOOSES NOT TO RUN AGAIN, FIRST
ON MY LIST AFTER HIM WOULD BE
KAMALA HARRIS.
>> DEMOCRATS SAYING IT'S
KAMALA'S TIME TO SHINE, NEVER
MIND POOR HANDLING OF THE
BORDER.
"I THINK SHE DOESN'T GET TO SHOW
THE PERSONALITY ENOUGH, SO
PEOPLE HAVEN'T HAD A CHANCE TO
KNOW HER.
MOST OF THE MEDIA IS WHITE AND
MALE, AND THEIR TAKE ON KAMALA
BECOMES CONVENTIONAL WISDOM."
JOY REID IS RIGHT.
HERE'S THE REAL KAMALA.
>> I EXPERIENCED GREAT JOY WHEN
I WATCHED THIS BRILLIANT,
PHENOMENAL BLACK WOMAN, JURIST,
BE SO SMART, AND JUST CUT
THROUGH THE POLITICAL
GAMESMANSHIP THAT THEY WERE
ATTEMPTING TO INSIGHT.
>> DANA, WHEN SHE SPEAKS SO
SLOWLY, IS SHE TRYING TO THINK
OF THINGS TO SAY OR IS SHE
TRYING TO SOUND VERY THOUGHTFUL?
>> PERHAPS A COMBINATION OF
BOTH, RIGHT?
>> OKAY.
>> SOMETIMES THE SENTENCES DON'T
MAKE AS MUCH SENSE AS THAT ONE
DID.
IT WASN'T AS MUCH AS A WORLD
SALAD AS WE'VE SEEN HEARD.
INTERESTING SINCE "THE NEW YORK
TIMES" FIRST BROKE THE SEAL,
SAYING JOE BIDEN SHOULDN'T RUN
AGAIN IN 2024, ANY OF THE
DEMOCRATS QUOTED SINCE ARE,
LIKE, "BUT WE HAVE KAMALA SO
EVERYTHING WILL BE FINE."
THERE'S NONE OF THAT EXCEPT FOR
CLYBURN, TRYING TO BE THE
STATESMAN AND TRYING TO BE KIND.
EVIDENCE OF THAT IS THEY HAD TO
CANCEL A FUNDRAISER BECAUSE NOT
ENOUGH PEOPLE WANTED TO PAY
$15,000 FOR A PHOTO WITH KAMALA
HARRIS.
NOW THERE'S AN EVENT IN ITS
PLACE ONLY CHARGING $5,000.
IF YOU'RE TRENDING DOWN ON THE
FUNDRAISING LEADING INTO THE
MIDTERM, IT'S HARD TO IMAGINE
THAT GOES BACK UP IN 2024.
>> HOW MUCH DO PEOPLE PAY FOR A
PICTURE WITH YOU?
>> 15 GRAND, BUT THEY GET MORE
THAN A PICTURE, JESSE.
MORE LIKE A VIDEO THAT GOES ON
FOR HOURS.
WHEN YOU SHOWED THAT VIDEO,
SOMEBODY HAD TALKED TO HER,
SAYING "YOU GOT TO PICK YOUR
WORDS MORE WISELY."
SHE USES WORDS LIKE CAR SALESMEN
USE COLOGNE, HOPING IT MASKS
SOMETHING.
REMEMBER THE FLYING WALLENDAS?
>> YES.
>> LIKE WATCHING A FLYING
WALLENDA TRYING TO CROSS A
TIGHTROPE BETWEEN TWO BUILDINGS.
YOU NEVER KNOW IF SHE'LL MAKE IT
TO THE OTHER END.
OFTENTIMES SHE DIS.
I LIKE WHEN PEOPLE SAY, "THE
REASON PEOPLE DON'T LIKE YOU IS
BECAUSE THEY DON'T KNOW YOU."
NO.
IT'S THE OPPOSITE.
THEY KNOW YOU.
IT'S LIKE WHAT THEY USED TO SAY
ABOUT HILLARY, "PEOPLE WHO KNOW
HILLARY, SHE'S A BARREL OF
LAUGHS."
YEAH, TILL SHE KILLS YOU
ALLEGEDLY.
WE ALWAYS TALK ABOUT HAVING A
DEEP BENCH.
IT'S A BASEBALL TERM, DANA.
>> GOT IT.
>> THE DEEMS DON'T HAVE A DEEP
BENCH.
THEY BAYLOR HAVE A SQUATTY
POTTY, AND IT'S FULL OF CRAP.
>> WHAT DO YOU THINK ABOUT
CLYBURN NOT SHUTTING DOWN THE
KAMALA TALK?
ALL HE HAS TO SAY IS "JOE BIDEN
IS DOING A GREAT JOB," AND
THAT'S IT?
>> HERE'S THE THING ABOUT
CLYBURN?
HE GAVE US JOE BIDEN.
OKAY?
GIVEN WHAT WE'VE HAD FOR THE
LAST YEAR AND A HALF, I'M NOT
INCLINED TO GO WITH HIM, WITH
HIS RECOMMENDATION.
YOU KNOW, THE BEST PART OF THIS
IS HOW WE'RE GOING TO TALK ABOUT
$15,000, $5,000.
MOST OF US AT THE TABLE WOULD
GET THAT MUCH.
YOU'D PROBABLY GET 15, GREG.
>> OH, THANK YOU.
>> BECAUSE OF THE VIDEO.
WHEN JOY REID SAID, "THE REASON
PEOPLE DON'T LIKE KAMALA, THEY
DON'T KNOW HER."
HERE'S THE THING.
I DON'T WANT TO GET TO KNOW HER.
I'VE SEEN ENOUGH.
I WANT HER TO BE A LEADER, WANT
TO ADMIRE HER.
I WANT LITTLE GIRLS TO LOOK UP
TO HER AND SAY, "I WANT TO BE A
VICE PRESIDENT LIKE THAT."
I DON'T NEED ANOTHER GIRLFRIEND.
I DON'T NEED TO GET TO KNOW HER
IN ORDER FOR HER TO BE
EFFECTIVE.
THE FACT THAT SOME WON'T SHOW UP
FOR THESE FUNDRAISERS, SHE'S A
TOTAL DISASTER.
64% OF AMERICANS DON'T WANT
BIDEN TO RUN AGAIN.
THAT'S A HUGE NUMBER.
I CAN'T IMAGINE THAT LAST NUMBER
I HEARD OF HER WAS 20% APPROVED
OF HER.
I DOUBT SHE'S GOING ANYWHERE.
I DON'T KNOW WHY THEY CONTINUE
WITH THIS CHARADE, "OH, YEAH,
HE'S DOING WHAT'S RIGHT, AND SHE
IS TOO."
THEY'RE NOT.
WE'RE IN A MESS.
>> SHE MIGHT BE A HIDDEN GEM,
THOUGH,.
>> MORE ON THAT LATER.
JOY SAYS SHE'S GETTING A BAD RAP
BECAUSE THE MEDIA IS MOSTLY MALE
AND MOSTLY WHITE.
WHAT ABOUT DICK?
WAS HE COVERED FAIRLY BY THE
MAINSTREAM MEDIA?
SAME WHITE MALE MEDIA DIDN'T
COVER HIM VERY WELL.
>> I THINK THAT -- I LISTEN TO
CONGRESSMAN CLYBURN CAREFULLY,
AND IT'S HARD FOR ME TO IMAGINE
THE PRESIDENT NOT SEEKING
RE-ELECTION.
SOME DEMOCRATS ARE CONCERNED
ABOUT HIS AGE.
I READ A STORY YESTERDAY, AND
THIS AGEISM STUFF I DON'T ENGAGE
IN, BUT DEMOCRATS NEED TO STOP
WORRYING ABOUT THE MENTAL AND
PHYSICAL ACUITY OF THE
PRESIDENT.
WE NEED TO FOCUS ON THE POLICY
ACUITY.
IF POLICIES WERE WORKING TO THE
EXTENT THAT SOME AROUND THE
TABLE WOULD AGREE WITH, THE
POLLING SUGGESTS A LOT OF THE
COUNTRY WANTS IT TO BE
DIFFERENT, WE WOULDN'T MIND IF
YOU STUMBLED OVER WORDS OR
STUMBLED UP THE STAIRS, BUT THE
COUNTRY IS SET FOR A STRONGER
SET OF POLICIES AT THE BORDER,
ON CRIME, INFLATION.
LAUNCHING ATTACKS WON'T WIN A
RACE IN TWO YEARS.
YOU HAVE TO LAY OUT A POSITIVE
VISION FOR THE COUNTRY.
IF YOU'RE ABLE TO DO THAT, ABLE
TO DEFEAT AN INCUMBENT
PRESIDENT, BUT YOU'RE NOT GOING
TO DEFEAT A PRESIDENT BY SAYING
"HE'S BAD, HE'S TERRIBLE, HE'S
OLD."
MONDALE LOST SAYING REAGAN WAS
TOO OLD OF A GUY.
THERE'S NO QUESTION, DEMOCRATS
AND BIDEN HAVE TO GET BETTER.
IF THEY DON'T GET BETTER,
REPUBLICANS ARE GOING TO BE ABLE
TO NOT ONLY LAUNCH A SERIOUS
CAMPAIGN BUT MAYBE A WINNING
CAMPAIGN.
>> MAYBE A WINNING CAMPAIGN?
WOULDN'T THAT BE SOMETHING?
>> IT WOULD BE SOMETHING.
YOU KNOW, THERE'S A POINT TO --
MAYBE IT'S TIME FOR YOUNGER MEME
TO BE IN OFFICE, YOU KNOW.
>> YEAH.
>> YOU KNOW, SOMEBODY LIKE ME.
>> YOU KNOW, I SUPPORT YOU IN
THAT CASE.
>> I'M NOT TALL ENOUGH.
>> YEAH, DEFIN